okay so let's get right into it point  number one you have all the time in the  world don't worry you're young you don't  need to have so much urgency but in  reality i've never met anybody that one  at the highest level with constantly  trying to take their time they can have  all the time in the world can you  imagine let's just have three o'clock  appointment to have a job interview and  you say your uncle says johnny just  watch one more quarter you have all the  time in the world don't worry about it  your homework's due tomorrow let's just  say you got the finals and your brother  says dude just let's play one more hour  of this video again don't worry you have  plenty of time the whole idea of you of  all the time in the world tend to get  everybody else to get calmer and what  i've found that when people say things  like that to me they're the ones that  are the most urgent they just want me to  kind of slow down so i can't catch up to  them